-Today might have been
the most devastating day
of the Trump presidency so far.
A key witness to the Ukraine
scheme provided evidence
that there was a quid pro quo
and that it was ordered by
the President himself.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today we heard from Trump's
hand-picked ambassador
to the European Union,
a guy named Gordon Sondland.
Sondland's testimony was
explosive, shocking,
and jaw-dropping,
and if you don't believe me,
let's just fast-forward to
the moment when after Democrats
finish questioning Sondland,
the camera cut over to
GOP Congressman Devin Nunes.
-That concludes our 45 minutes.
I now recognize Mr. Nunes.
-Oh.
-Okay.
Why don't we take
a 5- or 10-minute break?
-Thank you.
-Man, look at his face.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he just walked in
on his parents having sex
with someone else's parents.
[ Laughter ]
There's only two explanations
to that face.
Either he just heard
lengthy testimony
detailing a criminal scheme
so shocking it could bring down
the presidency of Donald Trump,
or he sharted
and he's trying to remember
how far away
his backup pants are.
[ Laughter ]
Sondland's testimony didn't just
go straight to President Trump
but also involved virtually
everybody at the highest levels
of the administration.
Sondland named every name
in the book.
-Secretary Perry,
Ambassador Volker,
Rudy Giuliani, Secretary Pompeo,
Brian McCormack,
Ms. Kenna,
Chief of Staff Mulvaney,
Rob Blair, Vice President Pence,
A$AP Rocky.
-He named A$AP Rocky!
[ Laughter ]
Sondland name-checked virtually
all of Trump's senior aides,
Vice President Mike Pence,
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo,
Energy Secretary Rick Perry,
Chief of Staff Mick Mulvaney,
and Trump's lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani.
Even the White House janitor was
like, "Am I gonna go to jail?"
[ Laughter ]
In short,
today we learned yet again
that the entire Trump
White House
is basically
one giant criminal conspiracy.
This was like the "Wizard of Oz"
of impeachment testimony.
"You were there,
and you were there,
and you were there too, mate!
You were the scarecrow!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, before we get to the rest
of today's bombshell testimony,
it's important to provide
some context for why today
was the most shocking day
of testimony so far.
Throughout this
impeachment process,
we've been watching
the Republican argument
morph in real time,
which makes sense because Trump
always looks like he's morphing.
He looks like an animorph
who's halfway between
human and bobcat.
[ Laughter ]
For example, you'll recall
that Trump began by insisting
there was no quid pro quo
with Ukraine
and that his phone call
with the president of Ukraine,
in which Trump
literally said the words,
"I would like you to do us
a favor" was perfect.
But as the impeachment process
has proved,
it definitely was not perfect.
Republicans have changed
their argument.
For example, yesterday
two credible witnesses
who were on Trump's call
called it
unusual,
inappropriate, and improper.
And even a Republican witness,
a national security official
named Tim Morrison,
said straight up that Sondland
had told him
Trump was holding up the
aid to Ukraine in exchange for
a promise from Ukraine
to announce publicly
that they were investigating
Trump's political rivals.
-What did Ambassador Sondland
say to tell you
that he told Mr. Yermak?
-That the Ukrainians would have
to have the prosecutor general
make a statement with respect to
the investigations
as a condition
of having the aid lifted.
-There you go.
That's literally a quid pro quo.
Republicans actually thought
calling this guy as a witness
would be a good idea.
They thought he would help their
case, but he only made it worse.
It's like if you murdered a guy
and called his ghost
as your witness.
[ Laughter ]
"He's the one who killed me!"
"Damn it, ghost!"
[ Laughter ]
"I thought you were on my side!"
So, after Tuesday's hearings,
Republicans decided to change
their argument again.
A house GOP aide described the
change of messaging this way.
It has gone from
"there is no quid pro quo"
"to there's a quid and quo
but not a pro,"
to "even if there was a quid pro
quo, it's not that bad.
This is just
how things are done.
You can say it's bad,
but it's not impeachable."
My God, look how much
their argument has changed.
This would be like if you got
pulled over and said,
"I wasn't speeding.
Okay, I was speeding.
Everyone speeds.
I was late for my job.
I work at the hospital.
So does my wife.
And she's having a baby,
and I was barely speeding.
Fine, I was really speeding
and my wife's not pregnant,
and I don't have a wife.
And also I'm drunk --
on cocaine."
[ Laughter ]
Which brings us
to today's hearing.
Remember Sondland,
hand-picked by Trump.
He's a businessman who donated
a million dollars
to Trump's inaugural committee
and he was a central figure
in Ukraine policy.
In fact, according to Morrison,
officials in
the Trump administration
even coined a term
for Gordon Sondland's role
in Ukraine policy.
-Among the discussions
I had with Dr. Hill
were about Ambassador Sondland.
I think she might have coined it
"the Gordon problem."
-That's what they called it,
"the Gordon problem?"
That sounds like a indie movie
about a single guy in his 40s
starring Ben Stiller.
[ Laughter ]
So today Sondland
had the chance to respond.
Again, Sondland, a key middleman
between Trump and Ukraine,
and he wrote down
what was happening
in several infamous
text messages,
and he started out his testimony
by stating
clearly and unequivocally
that everything they did,
they did at the direction
of the President himself.
-Secretary Perry,
Ambassador Volker, and I
worked with Mr. Rudy Giuliani
on Ukraine matters
at the express direction of the
President of the United States.
We followed
the President's orders.
We worked with Mr. Giuliani
because the President
directed us to do so.
-He literally said over and over
"the President
told us to do this."
And I believe it because no one
would work with Rudy Giuliani
unless they were ordered to.
[ Laughter ]
Working with Rudy is like when
your mom makes you hang out
with her friend's weird son.
"Why don't you take Rudy
to the mall with you?"
"Because he smells like onions
and he never stops screaming!"
After Sondland made clear
he carried out
the President's orders, he went
on to explain specifically
that what Rudy Giuliani wanted
was definitely a quid pro quo,
and that he did it specifically
because that's what
Trump wanted.
-Mr. Giuliani's request
were a quid pro quo
for arranging a White House
visit for President Zelensky.
Mr. Giuliani demanded that
Ukraine make a public statement
announcing the investigations
of the 2016 election DNC server
and Burisma.
Mr. Giuliani was
expressing the desires
of the President
of the United States,
and we knew these investigations
were important to the President.
-There it is. He just said it.
This was a quid pro quo, and it
definitely makes sense to me
that Rudy was expressing
the desires of the President.
Rudy looks like
the devil on Trump's shoulder
except Trump would never
need a devil.
"You should commit
quid pro quo."
"Way ahead of you, tiny devil!"
[ Laughter ]
Again Sondland made clear that
Trump had specifically directed
his administration,
people that actually work for
the U.S. government and get paid
with your taxpayer dollars
to orchestrate a quid pro quo
with Rudy Giuliani,
who has no official
government role.
And Sondland said
they were not happy about it.
-President Trump directed us
to "talk with Rudy."
We understood that
"talk with Rudy" meant
talk with Mr. Rudy Giuliani,
the President's personal lawyer.
Let me say again.
We weren't happy with
the President's directive
to "talk with Rudy."
-Of course they weren't happy.
No one is happy to talk to Rudy.
[ Laughter ]
If you get cornered by Rudy
at a party, your only option
is to pretend you're choking
and even then Rudy would only
make things worse.
"I know the Heimlich. Look!
I can do it on myself!"
[ Laughter ]
But this brings us
to a crucial point.
It wasn't just Trump and Rudy.
Sondland made it clear that
a number of high-level officials
in the Trump White House
and some people outside
the White House were aware of
what was happening
as it was happening.
Sondland said he had e-mails
to support his account,
and again, Sondland specifically
used the words "quid pro quo."
-These e-mails show that
the leadership
of the State Department,
the National Security Council,
and the White House
were all informed about
the Ukraine efforts.
I shared concerns of
the potential quid pro quo
regarding the security aid
with Senator Ron Johnson.
We kept the leadership of
the State Department and the NSC
informed of our activities.
And that included communications
with Secretary of State Pompeo.
They knew what we were doing
and why.
Everyone was in the loop.
Again, everyone was in the loop.
-Think about that. He just said
everyone was in the loop,
which makes clear once again
that these guys
are the worst criminals
in the world.
They orchestrated
an illicit scheme
to pressure a foreign country
to interfere in
a presidential election,
and they basically sent out
a staff-wide e-mail
CCing everyone.
Subject -- "Crimes."
"Hey, y'all, we're doing crimes.
Wanted to make sure
you all know about the crimes.
If you have questions
about the crimes,
please e-mail
crimes@whitehouse.gov/crimes."
Sondland also said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...he also said he reviewed
other State Department documents
that had been previously
not made public,
which must have scared the hell
out of Giuliani and Trump.
-I've reviewed other
State Department documents,
some of which are not currently
in the public domain,
detailing
Mr. Giuliani's efforts.
-The only part of that sentence
that shocks me
is they weren't in
the public domain.
Remember, Giuliani's already
done multiple TV interviews
where he literally held up
his phone and his iPad
to show off his communications
with Trump offi--
I mean, I'm shocked Rudy didn't
come sprinting into the hearing
with his phone in his hands,
screaming,
"He's right! I missed one!
It's right here!
I got a selfie of me in Ukraine
with a shirt that says
'I love quid pro quos!'"
[ Laughter ]
Sondland also provided
damning firsthand accounts
of his conversations with Trump
himself and had very specific
recollections of phone calls
he had with the President
where he asked him
what was going on.
-I thought it was a very bad
idea to hold that money.
I finally called the President.
I believe I just asked him
an open-ended question,
Mr. Chairman.
"What do you want from Ukraine?
I keep hearing all these
different ideas and theories
and this and that.
What do you want?"
And it was a very short,
abrupt conversation.
He was not in a good mood.
-That doesn't surprise me.
Trump's never in a good mood.
He only has two modes.
He's either screaming
at reporters
on the White House lawn
or glaring directly
into the camera like a burglar
caught on a doorbell camera.
I mean, look at him.
Compare his face to the face
Nunes is always making.
Nunes looks like a mailman
who just saw a Rottweiler
and Trump is the Rottweiler.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Sondland had multiple
conversations with Trump.
For example, you might remember
the infamous phone call
Sondland had with Trump in which
Trump was overheard asking
Sondland directly about
the investigations he wanted.
A State Department official who
was with Sondland at the time
also testified
that he overheard Sondland
tell Trump that
the President of Ukraine
would do anything for him
and that he "loves your ass."
And again, Sondland confirmed
that he did indeed
say that to Trump.
-He also testified that
you confirmed to President Trump
that you were in Ukraine
at the time
and that President Zelensky
"loves your ass."
Do you recall saying that?
-Yeah, it sounds like something
I would say.
[ Laughter ]
Putting it in Trump-speak
by saying he "loves your ass,
he'll do whatever you want"
meant that he would
really work with us.
-And that's the President
we got.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, the one who likes to
know how foreign leaders feel at
any given moment about his ass.
"Show them that picture of me
getting on the helicopter.
I think it looks really good
in that one."
[ Laughter ]
Now, today Trump responded to
Sondland's testimony
on his way to Texas
confirming that he spoke
to Sondland by phone.
But at first his account of that
call made no sense whatsoever.
-Just a quick comment on what's
going on in terms of testimony
with Ambassador Sondland,
and I just noticed one thing,
and I would say
that means it's all over.
"What do you want from Ukraine?"
he asks me.
Screaming, "What do you want
from Ukraine?
I keep hearing all these
different ideas and theories."
This is Ambassador Sondland
speaking to me.
Just happened, to which
I turned off the television.
"What do you want from Ukraine?
I keep hearing all of these
different ideas and theories.
What do you want?
It was a very short
and abrupt conversation
that he had with me.
They said he was not
in a good mood."
I'm always in a good mood.
I don't know what that is.
-First of all, that's the worst
audition for a school play
I've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
"Just so you know,
I'm not off book."
Second, you're never
in a good mood.
You're literally screaming
right now.
You can't scream,
"I'm always in a good mood."
That's a sentence
that refutes itself.
That's like a librarian
screaming,
"Everyone keep your [bleep]
voices down!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, Trump went on to quote
Sondland's testimony.
Sondland said that after months
of following the President's
explicit orders to carry out
the quid pro quo
he and Rudy wanted,
he called Trump
to get a straight answer.
Now, to be clear, this call
happened after the whistleblower
wrote their report
and officials expressed concern
about what Trump was doing.
So Trump suddenly
changed his tune
and he told Sondland,
"Never mind.
Forget about all of
that quid pro quo stuff."
-It was a very short,
abrupt conversation.
He was not in a good mood.
And he just said,
"I want nothing. I want nothing.
I want no quid pro quo.
Tell Zelensky
to do the right thing,"
something to that effect.
This is the final word
that I heard from
the President
of the United States.
-So here's my answer.
I want nothing. I want nothing.
I want no quid pro quo.
Tell Zelensky
to do the right thing.
Then he says,
"This is the final word from
the President
of the United States."
-Yeah, but no, it's not.
You already got caught.
That doesn't make you
sound innocent.
That sounds like the way
a criminal talks
when he thinks
his phone is tapped.
"I want nothing,
certainly not a quid pro quo
since that would be illegal.
And now I'm off to church
because I'm a good boy."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But if you're looking for
one single image
to capture everything
that happened today,
I direct you to this photo of
Sondland looking directly
into the camera
during a break in the hearing.
Damn, I mean,
he smelt it and dealt it.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like he's
in the opening credits
of "The Real Housewives."
[ Laughter ]
"My name is Gordon.
I may not quid or quo,
but I'm definitely a pro."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, he looks like he just
threw a match on a building
soaked in gasoline.
[ Laughter ]
Today was certainly
the most devastating day
in the impeachment process
so far,
and perhaps
the most devastating day
in the Trump presidency,
a key witness to
the corrupt quid pro quo
said he was following the orders
of the President
and named several
senior officials
who also knew about the scheme
and the Republican defense
crumbled before our eyes.
This is it.
If Republicans had any integrity
at all,
they'd look at the evidence
and tell Trump...
-That means it's all over.
-This has been "A Closer Look."